Trascrizione: Simona Punturello
Revisore: Giulia Sgarbossa
Ti ricordi gli incendi boschivi
in California nel 2020?
È un territorio che conosco molto bene
perché ho vissuto lì per quattro anni
durante i miei studi di dottorato.
Il cielo rosso era dovuto al fumo
provocato dagli incendi
che hanno devastato l’ovest
degli Stati Uniti in quell’anno.
Il fumo ha avvolto
la California per settimane
e ci ha costretto a rimanere in casa.
La qualità dell’aria in California è stata
la peggiore al mondo per settimane.
L’intensità e la durata di questi incendi
sono aumentate negli ultimi anni
e io stesso dal 2017 al 2020 ho
assistito all’aumento dei giorni di fumo.
La loro causa?
Il riscaldamento globale.
La temperatura media globale è già salita
di 1.1˚ rispetto all’epoca preindustriale.
In Italia la temperatura
è già salita di 2˚.
Un mondo 1.1˚ più caldo implica
condizioni estreme
come incendi boschivi
siccità e inondazioni.
Purtroppo stiamo continuando
a emettere gas serra
e di questo passo raggiungeremo
i tre gradi più caldi entro il 2050.
Un aumento di tre gradi
implica eventi ancora più estremi.
Il caldo e l’umidità ci terranno chiusi
in casa per diversi giorni in estate.
Siccità e inondazioni creeranno
rifugiati dovuti alla crisi climatica
e creeranno carestie dovute
alla perdita di raccolti.
Quindi saremo tutti influenzati
dal cambiamento climatico,
non ci sarà nessun luogo o nessuna persona
che non verrà influenzata.
Nel 2019 le Nazioni Unite hanno detto che
per mitigare il cambiamento climatico
è necessario raggiungere la neutralità
carbonica o emissioni zero entro il 2050.
Emissioni zero significa
raggiungere un equilibrio
tra la quantità di CO2
emessa nell’atmosfera
e la quantità di CO2 assorbita
o rimossa dall’atmosfera.
Per raggiungere questo obiettivo
molto ambizioso ma necessario
in Europa si stanno progettando strategie
per rimuovere milioni di tonnellate
di CO2 dall’atmosfera.
Una di queste strategie è la bioenergia
con cattura e sequestrazione del carbonio.
Questa strategia consiste nel convertire
le piante in bioenergia.
Qui le piante vengono trasportate in siti
per essere convertite in energia
e possiamo produrre diversi tipi
di bioenergia dalle piante
come il calore e l’elettricità
ma anche combustibili
come il gas naturale,
il metano e l’idrogeno.
Durante la produzione di bioenergia
si produce un flusso puro di CO2
che, venendo dalle piante,
è rinnovabile o biogenica.
Questa CO2 è catturata, liquefatta
e trasportata con treni, navi, camion
o condotti in appropriati siti
per essere iniettata nel sottosuolo
a profondità superiori al chilometro
e quindi essere sequestrata
nel sottosuolo in modo permanente.
Con i miei colleghi abbiamo quantificato
il potenziale di questo piano in Europa
e abbiamo trovato che la bioenergia
con cattura e sequestrazione del carbonio
può mitigare il 7%
delle emissioni europee.
Mentre il 7% potrebbe sembrare
un numero molto piccolo,
corrisponde a 280 milioni
di tonnellate di CO2 all’anno.
280 milioni di tonnellate di CO2
corrispondono a 16 milioni di tir
o a 7 miliardi di forme
di Parmigiano Reggiano.
Quindi stiamo parlando
di quantità enormi di CO2
che potrebbero essere rimosse
dall’atmosfera.
In Europa esistono dieci siti
adibiti allo stoccaggio della CO2
che sono in fase di approvazione.
Questi siti sono principalmente
localizzati nel Mare del Nord
a eccezione di uno
che è il polo di Ravenna, in Italia.
Questi siti sono stati scelti perché
erano infrastrutture adibite
a estrarre petrolio e gas naturale
e si sta pensando di riconvertire
queste infrastrutture
per iniettare nel sottosuolo la CO2
e sono stati scelti perché,
conoscendo la loro geologia,
siamo molto sicuri che la CO2 potrà essere
intrappolata per sempre nel sottosuolo.
Questa strategia della bioenergia
con cattura e sequestrazione del carbonio
può rimuovere circa 1/3 della CO2
che dovrà essere rimossa dalle nazioni EU
per mitigare il cambiamento climatico,
raggiungere emissioni zero
e bilanciare le emissioni
da settori difficili da decarbonizzare
come la produzione di cemento e acciaio,
l’aviazione e l’agricoltura.
Purtroppo, essendo molto costosa,
non è fattibile senza un supporto sociale,
politico ed economico.
Io come scienziato contribuisco
studiando soluzioni
per mitigare il cambiamento climatico.
Tu puoi contribuire dando il tuo supporto
e consenso a queste strategie innovative.
Grazie.